your daughter I just find out I just
leave her is because last time I was
talking to you she had just been born
she's your role yeah now yes I have a
one-year-old incredible life-changing
wonderful beautiful experience yeah I'm
trying my best to not be like every
other parent who acts when their child
is first born like they're the first
person to ever have a kid and force
photos of her own people when I see them
yeah but that said I thought I would
show the first ever photo of her this is
cool it's the first-ever photo of my
daughter there she is okay that's not
her okay all right see the real
truthfully this one is real pick out now
okay here we go the sweet little angel
hope it wasn't a natural child it came
it came along quite easily oh yeah okay
he's a sweet one although I've made the
mistake a few times she gets very grumpy
and I fed her after midnight
no boy yeah she looked more like that oh
that's not good yeah you're gonna show a
real picture it was okay that was your
firm gremlin way to really connect with
this audience just to really show a
picture okay that's the way to really
connect with this crowd
always just show that you're a real
person yes and not just one of those
jokesters fine I'm no jokester here is
the real picture that's so not yours
that well you did it you really connect
it with the crowd there's a chip off
[Laughter]
you